how logical are you given below are two
statements and four conclusions based on
the statements statement one some
bottles are cups statement two all cups
are knives write true or false if each
conclusion can be logically inferred a
some bottles are knives B some knives
are cups C all cups are bottles D all
knives are cups
we can work this out by drawing a Venn
diagram we know that some bottles are
cups so these two sets must have some
overlap then all cups are knives so the
set of knives is a superset of Cups
conclusion a some bottles are knives
well this overlapping region will be
bottles that are knives so this is true
B some knives are cups this region here
will be knives that are cups this is
true see all cups are bottles the same
region will be cups that are not bottles
this is false d all knives are cups
these are knives that are not equal to
cups so this will be false so the answer
is a and b are true